welcome back to beautiful uncensored
world next to golfing superstar who's
just become the third englishman in 52
years to win the us open memphis patrick
follow the footsteps of tony jackman in
1917 justin rose in 2013 to win the
major title so where did he get his
inspiration for such greatness i'll ask
him in a moment but first let's take a
look at that winning moment
[Applause]
so so close
and it's a dream come true
for magnificent
and the us open title fits perfectly
[Applause]
i'm glad to say i'm joined now from
america by matt fitzpatrick u.s open
champion no less
how are you
i'm good pierce how are you have you
been sleeping with that trophy be honest
um it's been next to me every night so
far so yeah pretty much
only you could win your first major by
not actually doing anything watching
somebody else miss a putt
[Laughter]
i knew i knew you'd have an ac you have
an answer for everything
you know what it was absolutely
incredible to watch it and because i
know you quite well i know how much it
means to you um that moment when you
realized you were the champion you'd won
your first major you were the us open
champion and then you turn and you you
turn to your caddy who normally in that
moment would be as jubilant as you and
he's broken down in tears billy foster
because he's waited 40 years to carry a
bag for a major champion
yeah it's um
it was incredibly surreal um you know i
know what it means to billy and and as
you say you know what it means to me and
um
for me to to win a major it's uh
it's 10 million times better than i ever
thought it would feel uh i've got to
admit it's uh it's truly been incredible
and uh that moment when it you know when
the pup missed and and i knew knew that
i was gonna i was the winner then
uh it was truly incredible
you're an incredibly fastidious golfer
in the sense that you've made a note of
every shot you've ever played as a
professional and you've kept all these
notebooks
why do you do that and do you think
that's been one of the reasons why
you've ended up a major champion
yeah i think uh for me it's
i do it just to you know figure out
where where i can improve all the time
uh where my strengths are where my
weaknesses are
um and i definitely think it's been a
big part in helping me succeed in my
career so far just because of
you know i i've got the information on
where i need to to get better all the
time and and
because of that i'm i'm using my time
efficiently rather than kind of wasting
it on something that might be a strength
already so
um i feel like that that's been a big
part of my career and um you know i'm
certainly going to continue doing it and
i think it's helped massively you've
gone from matt fitzpatrick and i mean
this in the nicest possible way kind of
nearly man
not quite winning a major you know one
of the pros not a household name and
then now suddenly within 48 hours you're
on the front page of newspapers all over
the world you're on tv shows all over
the world your life has just changed
irrevocably are you enjoying it are you
slightly apprehensive about what may now
happen
yeah i mean i'm definitely apprehensive
you know there's uh
you've seen it with with other guys that
have had success and then maybe don't
play so well and and some guys that have
success and continue on to go and do
more it's
um there's always a little bit of that
at first and
uh it might take some time to sort of
get used to to everything that's going
on and
um but you know i'm excited it's it's
what i've worked so hard for to achieve
this so
um you know got to understand everything
else that comes with it and
just try and take it in my stride as
best as possible and and enjoy it at the
same time it's like i say it's what i've
worked for so you know you've got to
enjoy it once you've achieved what you
want absolutely i i read a fascinating
uh piece in the papers today that you
were inspired in a way by conversation
you had with your ex-girlfriend denise
whose family are from ukraine and you
had this when the ukraine war started
and you spoke on the phone and she told
you some stuff about her family and what
they were going through
in the ukraine that gave you a new
perspective
yeah yeah i mean you know that was that
was obviously back in back in march time
and um
i think obviously with everything that's
going on
in in ukraine right now and
um particularly obviously being being
close to that and
and having that experience of someone in
or knowing someone that has has is going
through that it was uh
it was obviously
tough to to see and tough to understand
from my side but it like i say like you
say it made me realize that
you know put things into perspective at
the end of the day i'm only playing golf
and um you know there's much worse
things going on
and um
it definitely it definitely helped
you know my mental game
towards towards my golf and uh whilst i
was playing tournaments
there was a story breaking just before i
came out to do this chat with you that
brooks kepker is likely to be the next
recruit for this live tour the
saudi-sponsored sort of renegade tour uh
your brother was quite interesting about
this he said that you persuade he's also
a top golfer you persuaded him
not to join that tour as you've decided
not to join it what what do you feel
about where this debate is now going
given that players of the caliber of
deshambo and brooks kepler and other top
top players are now doing this and of
course running the risk of being banned
from the main pga tour
yeah listen you know it's it's their
choice it's their careers and and
they've got to do what's right for them
um
for me personally
you know
i grew up watching
the open the us open the masters um
the rbc heritage on on the pga tour
um wentworth the bmw pga at wentworth on
the dp world tour those are events that
mean something to me
um growing up as a kid watching those
those are what i wanted to play in what
i wanted to try and win
um
and because of that that's you know
that's that's why i'm
committed to to the dp world tour and
and the pga tour because that those are
the ones that i grew up watching um
and i think for me like i say it's it's
it's everyone else's decision that they
you know they can do what they feel is
right for them and i absolutely have no
issues with that or whatever they want
to do but for me personally
i think
the right way to go um is for me to
stick where i am and play the pga tour
and
uh the dp will torso um but i think it's
an interesting time for golf and
uh it's certainly gonna be interesting
to see how it all works out is it gonna
have to be a deal do you think given the
the sheer number of top players that are
beginning to to migrate over there
they're gonna have to eventually say
look players really which is what i
believe by the way should be allowed to
play where they want to play
yeah i mean listen i i do i i do agree
with you there i do believe that players
should should be able to play where they
want to play um
the
a lot of the times people say that we
are independent contractors which i
guess we are
um
so yeah i do you know like i say i
respect where wherever people want to go
wherever they want to play i've got no
issues with that um they've got to do
what's best for them um whether they'll
be a deal
i you know i i i couldn't possibly
answer that
um
there might be there might not be it's
uh it's obviously all up in the air
um you know the rumors of players
leaving every day and um
you know for me that's sitting on the
outside of it it's uh
i'm finding it pretty interesting to to
see whose name's gonna pop up next
really so yeah um i guess we'll just
have to see what happens
i've got some clips to play you uh each
with their own little story you may
remember that probably the most
inspiring
golf rounds of your career probably been
with me
uh one in the british masters
program where you witnessed me actually
getting a net hole in one and we have a
video to prove that here's the video
so matt fitzpatrick obviously fresh off
the ryder cup could you tell me how i
just uh performed on that last hole
please
well obviously we didn't take your [ __ ]
tee shot because it was finished short
of the one how many did i score but
you managed to spawnily hold a pot
for a two net hole in one so well done
thank you very much matt fitzpatrick
so i felt that playing with you i just
felt like i gave you that extra level of
of confidence and bravado that you
needed to make that next leap up to
major champion
you know i i've got credit where
credit's due peers it's uh that's all i
was thinking about on sunday was you
know your words and your advice you put
in tips your bunker tips it's uh
you know forget forget my team it's you
know all the credit is is down to you
thank you matt fitzpatrick i'm very glad
you're finally recognizing the massive
contribution i've made to your victory
um
the other game we played which was
actually hilarious was we played in in
l.a you wanted a game a warm-up game yes
i got you on a course called lakeside in
los angeles lovely course with a lot of
actors play they're entertainers vinnie
jones was our host which in itself was
surreal enough and then halfway around
joe pesci from goodfellas rocked up in a
golf buggy and here's the picture of us
all together and all i remember is that
you were playing great on the front line
but the moment joe pesci turned up your
game collapsed he kept staring at you
and you couldn't basically hold a part
after that
yeah well you know when you've got
famous actors like that watching over
you it's uh yeah that's way more
pressure than than any any other event
i've ever played so
uh but no we had a fun day that day it
was uh very enjoyable and um
it's uh it's a great photo actually i
saw it the other day for the first time
uh since since it was taken so uh yeah
it was good fun well i've got a little
message for you from vinnie jones who
was watching your triumph and he's he
says this
how you doing matt well done son so
proud of you everybody as the nation is
with you
i'm glad your bum weren't shaking in
that bunker like it was when joe pesci
came over and
started watching us play golf at
lakeside well done mate we're really
proud of you
don't take too much stick off of peers
we'll get you a better partner next time
cheers mate what's up boy
you say you want to win six majors which
would of course match you with the
greats and nick faldo he's just he's
just quit today as a commentator he's
retiring he's going to go off and do his
golf courses over that what's your
feeling about that
yeah you know that's it's a shame you
know nick's great on the broadcast um i
know not a lot of people like him over
here and
um being lucky enough to spend a little
bit of time with him and pick his brain
about a few things so
um no enjoy my time with nick and i'm
sure he'll enjoy his full retirement now
now he's uh
he's not doing that anymore he'll
probably get a bit more time to play
golf again
well matt you're already sounding like
an experienced major winner you know
you've got the kind of cool
the cool chat now haven't you it's all
very you said almost mcelroy like now so
i have every confidence that given the
help that i've given you your career
given we've now got a major under our
belt between us uh you'll go on to ever
greater things absolutely uh but
honestly mate it couldn't happen to a
nicer guy you're one of the most
down-to-earth people i've met in sport
your family are fantastic i'm so
thrilled for them billy's fantastic your
caddy and i think everyone's just really
tough for all of you congratulations
what a moment for you to be the us thank
you open champion uh and i'm just so
glad you agree it's all down to me
thanks pierce i appreciate it
[Laughter]
all the best
you